so by the year 2050s there are going to
be more than two billion people who are
older than 60 years old and it has been
estimated that around 80% of these two
billions people will live in low and
middle inome countries which is roughly
the developing countries it is currently
a common beliefs globally that senior
citizens should not work do not need to
work and therefore there's a reason for
companies to create job for them I think
this kind of thinking the thinking that
senior employment is in essential is
actually a seeds of a major problem that
could impact a lot of lives especially
lives of people in developing countries
to explain to you why let me show you a
diagram and let me call this diagram a
negative aging spiral imagine a 50 years
old living in a developing countries
that the chance that this person will
work later on will be slim so this
person is not going to invest in their
skill might not even invest in their
health because there's no return from
this investment then at the age of 60
this person is going to stop working
because it's it's common thing to do in
these
countries and then after that many bad
things could happen for example this
person might not have enough saving or
maybe no saving at all and now there's
no more employment opportunity this
person might feel lost feel hopeless
feel lonely this person might even feel
like there's no purpose to continue
living so it seems like for many people
in developing countries there's going to
be suffering through the process of
population
aging is there anything we can do
differently for me as an economist who
has been working on this topic of
population aging especially in the
context of developing countries for many
years I have been puzzle by these
questions but I think I've got an answer
I think the best Catalyst that we can
use to break the negative aging spiral
and unlock the power of population
edging is to create something called
senior employment Technologies and use
it to democratize senior
employment what is senior employment
Technologies it is a technology that can
be used to reduce or remove physical and
cognitive barrier for work for seniors
citizens like people wearing glasses
today and we use it to you know uh erase
or or remove our vision problem senior
employment Technologies is something
that we can use to you know transform
senior employment from scarcities to
abundance but unfortunately this aspect
of Technologies has been overlooked by a
lot of people when when we actually
think about it you know senior living
assisted Technologies are are quite
common but not so much in terms of
senior employment Technologies and in
the context of for example developed de
countries these Technologies do exist in
some extent but in a context of
developing countries these Technologies
is largely
non-existent so if we could create
senior employment Technologies and use
our imagination to think about what it
could be what would it be look like let
me give you guys a couple of
example the first group of senior
employment Technologies is something
that can be called physical augmentation
Technologies there are two types of
physical barrier to work the first one
is physical barrier at work so as we age
we tend to lose some of our physical
abilities for example we lose our muscle
strength we might lose our hand and
finger dexterities
now let's imagine the possibility if we
could create cheap and accessible
exoscale
Technologies in which it is a suit that
senior citizen could wear and this suit
can be used to augment for example trunk
muscle and senior citizen can actually
use it to lift something heavy but it
doesn't feel that heavy now if you
actually think about it this aspects of
Technologies is could be pretty
important in the context of developing
countries because a lot of people in
developing countries actually using
their body or their labor a lot for work
next let's imagine a possibility if we
could create cheap and accessible
collaborative robots or cobots in short
which is often in the form of robot arms
and these robot arms can be used as an
extra Steady Hand that you know senior
citizen can be used to recover um their
hand and finger dexterity especially for
work that require
Precision one interesting use case for
this could be for something like think
about senior surgeon in developing
countries in which we all can agree that
you know we we wouldn't want you know a
surgeon with shaking hand right to doing
anything near our body but you know
these Technologies can help uh you know
senior surgeon with amazing skill
amazing knowledge uh to still you know
make significant contributions and we
know you know in the period of
population aging surgeon doctors you
know will be in great shortage
the next physical barrier to work is the
physical barrier in getting to work
itself so as we age things like getting
stuck in traffics or being in a you know
a congested public transportation for so
long or need to take long distance Long
walking distance uh you know could be a
major you know barrier to work for for
many people for many senior citizen now
if a work does not require physical
presence let's imagine the possibility
that a technology like remote working
technology such as you know Zoom or
maybe in the future metaverse can be
used to completely remove the journey to
work itself and allow senior citizen to
work from anywhere anytime or maybe in
any
countries if a work does really require
physical presence let's imagine the
possibility that a technology like you
know Smart City technologies that one
aspect of smart City Technologies focus
it on you know
optimizing uh city transportation
resources by collecting data uh
informations and then you know from
sensors of from cameras and use it to
improve the journey to work for senior
citizens so that their journey to work
can be better and
safer the second group of senior
employment Technologies is something
that can be called a cognitive
augmentation Technologies so as we age
we also tend to lose some of our
cognitive abilities for example we tend
to lose uh you know our ability to
memorize things or our abilities to you
know compare pictures objects which is
called perceptual
speeds let's imagine the possibility
that you know maybe our cell phone our
laptop or maybe a virtual reality
glasses can be equipped with cognitive
augmentation software powered by
artificial intelligence which can be
used as a companion brand so in the
future this device can be used to help
uh you know senior citizen senior worker
to you know show them information work
related information as needed so they
don't need to memorize everything which
would be great for me right now too and
um you know help enhance for example
perceptual speeds when you know senior
workers senior citizen need to you know
identify objects or finding defects and
they can actually make the final
decision you know better and
faster of course Beyond
physical barrier and cognitive barrier
that I have been
mentioned we still need to find way to
remove social barrier to work which is
called the atheism beliefs it's the
beliefs that senior citizen are always
less productive than younger worker for
any kind of
occupation I think senior employment
Technologies can take us one step closer
to remove or maybe significantly reduce
ages and
beliefs I think if we can do this thing
we can break the negative aging spiral
and create something that can be called
a positive aging spiral imagine a 50
years old living in a developing
countries but in this case this person
actually invests in their skill this
person actually invest in their health
because they know this investment will
be value and not only that this person
actually looking forward to the next
journey in their lives then at the age
of 60 senior citizen who are qualified
work or could become qualified work
because of senior employment
Technologies and this person need or
want work should be able to work if we
can do this I think we can achieve and
become a wealthy and healthy aging
Society so by using these Technologies
senior employment Technologies in which
when we think about Technologies what we
have you know listen some technologies
might seem scary some might seems
concerning but I think senior employment
Technologies is the right kind of
technologies that our world our society
needs more right now and we can use
senior employment Technologies to
transforms and democratize Senior
employment from scarcity to abundance
and I think we can use it to transform
the lives of many people from suffering
through the process of population aging
to flourishing in the process of
population aging thank you very much